climate campaigner gratitude berg sails
into lisbon after 20 days at sea the 16
year old on her way to the UN climate
conference in Madrid bringing a singular
message with her we need to work
together to make sure that we secure
future living conditions humankind and
that we fight for not only ourselves but
for for our children and for our
grandchildren and for every single
living being on earth and everyone has
to do everything they can in order to
make sure they are on the right side of
history in Madrid the scientists are
leaving no room for doubt about how
critical the situation is highlighting
our steadily increasing temperatures
warning the last decade is almost
certain to have been the hottest on
record pleading for more action we are
not at all moving towards 1.5 to 2
degrees target at the moment we are
moving towards 3 to 5 degrees warming by
the end of this this century and but we
have all the economic and and financial
means to solve this problems and the
political will and carats of the of the
policymakers is needed even the World
Health Organization has joined the
chorus of alarm about the impact of our
carbon intensive lives air pollution is
responsible for 7 million primitive
deaths every year so is so obvious is so
cost effective he's so positively so no
controversial because who will disagree
with the fact that you want to reduce 7
million that except even here there are
disagreements about how to tackle the
problem delivering change is proving
harder than anyone imagined in part
that's because the biggest polluters
like China and especially America still
aren't doing enough but it's an even
broader problem than that and that's
because globally there is still a huge
gap between all the commitments that
have been made and what actually needs
to be done to limit the very worst
consequences of climate change
the effects of global warming in
evidence all over the world the Madrid
conference is supposed to help close
that gap whether it will despite all the
ambition isn't certain Hanna Thomas
Peter Sky News Madrid